but let me fill you in there guys
yes anthony edwards there's a ball head
right over the bag kerilov
has a hit the first hit that he has
pulled digging for second
and he is in with a double
seen him pick up hits just about
everywhere but there
right over the first base bag and right
on cue
another one of these young rookies in
minnesota done a nice job of
adjusting completely missed his spot
trying to go away with that ball but
still able to turn on and get the good
part of the bat out front
of the zone and then his target field
not a lot of foul territory once you get
down
those lines a little bit kick right to
the outfielder
slides into second and once again
provides a spark for this offense
high fly right field gallows got a
really good arm
here loft will try to advance and here
is the throw and it's a little too
strong
and now rolling up the warning track and
carol off is gonna score
you gotta love the aggressiveness of
youth you know a guy who's been around
and understands maybe gallows arm a
little bit better doesn't chance and
yellow actually overthrew third base on
the fly on that play
he just sailed this thing and looked
like kirloff probably would have been
safe but
that's one of those third out of third
base potential plays and ella looked
like maybe he had a little trouble
getting out of his glove
again gallow took a fastball for
a split finger pitch rather to recall
third strike
leading off the second
went upstairs and got him
maeda strands two more in scoring
position in the third
the rise might be the ideal guy to have
up there
high on base percentage
there's a drive to the right field
corner down for a hit
and gallow will fire a lower arc throw
right on the bag and her eyes holds up
with a sink
well good read he was going all the way
to second until he saw that ball kick
right back to gallow and he played this
perfectly off the wall
and now donaldson down the line into the
corner arise hustling around second
to third being waved around
throw from the short field in left hand
[Applause]
out at the plate and a collision at the
plate
a good relay by isaiah keiner falefa
and we'll see if our eyes is okay it
looked like he ran right into the shin
guards
of the catcher the twins are going to
look at the play
hopefully ryze is all right here he was
going to slide and the throw took him so
far off line that
smart move right here to get up and just
make go back and touch it look i think
he's going to be safe
and i wonder too i mean the catcher has
the right to try to catch
the ball but the catcher trevino
had to reach to catch the ball and block
the sliding leg
that might be what the challenge is all
about
now arise is smiling so safe
and donaldson will be positioned at
second base
so the rangers are three games below 500
but only four games out of first place
three more wins than the twins played
three more games the twins missing those
two that they
had canceled in anaheim
breaking ball tapped in front of
donaldson bear handing and firing
what a scoop at first by kerala a great
play by josh donaldson
and the rookie at first base dug it out
well he had one yesterday they probably
would like to head back and simmons got
an error on this one he was out here
early
today working on this working on balls
in the dirt working on picking balls and
just like this and this is a all or
nothing bare hand
goes out and gets it and that's not an
easy pick from where that ball hit
right on the lip of the grass it kind of
in that area that
can be tricky for a first base but
right off the end of the bat to kira
out of my aida two down
and that time on a check swing he got
him
another strikeout for maeda he has
eight of them through five innings
one and 0 to solar
sharply hit nice pickup by donaldson
on target to carol
you get a nice ovation as he's coming
out of this game right here with the
last better he faced but
a lot to build up of there at the end of
that start he really battled through
simmons niftaly picks it up and throws
to first and kirilov digs it out
on the backhand side again
the rangers threaten but do not score it
is two to nothing
is he going to go to it again in a 3-1
count is going to show basically the
same sequence and the same type of
hitters count
to left dahl over to the gap and he
can't get there
kirilla delivers again buxton scores on
another double
by alex caraloff well they had him
shifted in the outfield deal the infield
they play the shift with the three
infielders on the right side in the
outfield here they had dahl was almost
standing on the foul line
much like we used to see alex gordon
play when joe mauer was up but
kiriloff doing a nice job of staying on
this ball hitting it hard again
as we've seen him do so many times this
time was the
forcing fastball he went out there it
didn't go with the cutter and because
doll is standing so far he's got to go
so far to his left right here
overshifting almost covering if he hits
a foul ball right there
to center garcia going back still going
back
and the wind pushing it off his glove
kiriloff will score
polanco round second he'll gain third
base
and the twins had another run and the
wind
blew that ball away from the center
fielder and almost off the wall
inside driving it the other way i think
this will go down as a triple even
though it hit off his glove he ran a
long way for this ball ended up jumping
late
anticipating contact with that wall kind
of short armed it a little bit
first game playing center field this
ballpark so
a lot of room out there to run but
either way the twins will take the run
and increase the lead
and now to center kepler flares one into
center for an rbi
single and polanco scores from third
one pitch and that ball hit out to left
field
does it have enough it's gone
a two-run homer for garcia
and i don't know that he got all of it
but he got enough
and it puts the rangers on the board
it's a 5-2 ball game
even the way that he looked at it we
know that he knows when he gets one as
you're going to see
another attempt at going fastball in
that one at 93 miles an hour remember
the first pitch of that at-bat
was almost that exact same pitch that
garcia missed
i see how that's almost like floating a
little bit like he didn't sting that
baseball obviously he hit it hard enough
and he hits this one on the ground short
stop it'll get a run to the plate
throw the first in time they get
culverson but he picks up an rbi
and it's 5-3
that's it toward the gap in left center
field down for a hit
and it gets by dahl carol off around
third and polanco comes through with a
huge
rbi double in the eighth inning
[Applause]
[Music]
well nice to be able to answer back
another hard hit ball that
finds a gap for the twins and you know
things as an offense are really starting
to turn
it's a good sign
gallow is walked and singled he scored a
run
oh that ball hit out to right field and
carrying well
gone
it's a one-run game of the ninth deading
as
gallow hits a two-run blast to right
field
and he's come through in the ninth
and joey gallo took a really big swing
at a fastball in the first pitch of this
at-bat then he gets
another one and it's a two-seamer so
it's got a little bit of run in it
actually finished
off the plate it was a ball and joey
gets all of this one i remember
he's been pretty comfortable in this
ballpark
it's not the first one-run win for the
twins it just
feels that way rogers gets the save
and the twins win it 6-5